they died battling the worst fire in
Arizona state history thousands of acres
of grassland decimated by a deadly blaze
low humidity caused by a recent heatwave
combined with strong winds meant that
nothing could stop the fire as it ripped
through the tinder dry vegetation high
desert region we have a lot of mountains
and it's covered with fresh instead of
trees we've been having an extreme
drought and we've been having extreme
temperatures it's been nearly a hundred
and twenty degrees and so the
combination of the two is pretty deadly
houses were evacuated in nearby towns
and roads closed as hundreds of
firefighters were deployed to battle the
20-foot high flames 18 of the
firefighters that were killed on Sunday
evening were part of the same unit a
group of firefighters called the
Prescott Granite Mountain hotshots a
specially trained team they were forced
to deploy protective tents known as fire
shelters designed to shelter them from
heat and flames but the fire was too
intense it was later confirmed that
another firefighter had also been killed
typical of a fire like this we send many
many crews from all over the state the
wildland crew from the city of Prescott
Arizona was deployed to that and as a
result of circumstances that I'm not
aware of or have not been informed of
yet our entire crew was lost we lost 19
people in this wildfire the cause of the
fire is currently under investigation
but it's now believed that it was
started by a lightning strike James
Banks Sky News